foreign
let's go to Los Angeles California and
talk to Anna you're near what's up Anna
Hi how are you I I don't know I don't
know
I'm not very good at my job today how
are you
uh same I don't I don't know I can't
answer that all right I will help I'll
help you if you'll help me how about
that yeah let's do it
all right so what's up
um so my question is
um
that is it was
um if my favorite do me a favor take a
huge huge deep breath as deep as you can
and hold it
one two three let it out
and then do do that one more time as
deep as you can all the way from the
inside of your guts
one two three drop it okay
all right I'm with you
okay
um if my husband's cheating no no
I knew what you're gonna ask as you were
asking a question no
why in the world would you think that
and the messages and everything
and I told him oh
check your hidden album
he looked at me smiled
like the most evil smile I've ever seen
them do and said you've had nine years
to be the woman I love
I'm sorry I'm so sorry
I want you to consider a guy that would
so
um
disgusting is the word uh cheat on his
wife
is a person of so low character that the
words they say
aren't to be trusted either
so don't not trust him and don't not
trust his actions but then take a piece
of the ugliest most hurtful thing he
said and trust that as truth because
it's a lie too
yeah
so what's your next move
um I don't know because he's been
treating me since I was nine months
pregnant and we have a eight month old
now
you still staying in the home
he actually shipped this
we were living in Collin County Texas
and he shipped us off to California
because this is where my mom is this is
where my family is and his family too
and he put us on a plane three months
ago
um and now he's saying he wants to work
things out and fight for his family and
fight you know be in my baby's life but
it wasn't just
it wasn't just me he was he's a first
responder so his his work schedule is 24
hour shifts
and he was pretending to work a lot of
overtime and making trades and going and
spending
you know days with this other woman
from our gym and um
I told them it wasn't I've been there
when when my dad said oh I'm not leaving
your mom or I'm not leaving you girls
I'm leaving your mom too I said I know
how this works
you're not you're you say you're leaving
me but you're also you're not leaving
the baby you're just leaving me but you
don't call you don't FaceTime him you
don't initiate things to see him and he
says well because I I have to deal with
you and I don't want to deal with you so
I'd rather not if it means I don't have
to see him then
you understand that that doesn't make
sense on its face
yeah and that's exactly what I
and it doesn't matter stop let's do this
let's do this
you are in the
smoke and fog and Ash of a fire that
just burned right through your house
and you're trying to forensically figure
out why in the world this fire burned
and what it burned you got to get out of
the burned spot
okay
um as far as I'm concerned right now
your marriage is over
yeah behavior is a language he has told
you loud and clear
he does not want to be a father
he does not want to be a husband
he doesn't want to be a person of
character or integrity
because here's what I know
if let's say
I God forbid I had a long-term affair
behind my wife's back
and she caught me
and I took that Affair and I stabbed her
with it like he did with you
and then
I was such a spineless coward
that I put my wife and newborn on a
plane and sent them away out of our home
let's say I did all that and then I woke
up one day
and I realized I couldn't breathe and I
realized I had made the craziest most
insane mistake of my life
I don't pick up a phone or a text
message and say I really want to fight
for this
I find the nearest First I find the
first flight out and if there's not a
first flight I drive
and I bang the door down and say I've
made the most catastrophic mistake of my
life I quit my job I quit everything
because you are everything
that's what you do
and so
I'm gonna tell you something crazy I'm
not hating on him for having an affair
those are wrong and they happen
but he's been a he's displayed a gross
lack of character
yes sir and he's trying to drag his you
through his guilt right
yes
so what you've got to stop doing is
trying to make rational a an insane
irrational Act
you are allowed to be pregnant Anna if
that's answering your question
mm-hmm
were you always uh roses and
a joy to be around probably not no no
did he come to you and say hey I feel
like I'm losing my wife I want to
reconnect let's no he didn't do that he
went to the gym
yeah okay
and to be fair you didn't either
but no he made a choice
he looked you in the eye and he said for
you forever and then one day he went to
the gym and was like eh and her
made a choice
okay
so from this second forward you can no
longer carry the cinder block that is
his choices that's not your fault
mm-hmm
the question you've got to ask yourself
is what is Anna gonna do next because
right now he doesn't get a vote he
kicked you all out cool I'm gonna go
make my life
yeah that's that's what I said I said I
don't feel comfortable going back to
Texas absolutely not
he kicked you out you and your newborn
who kicks out a newborn
there's been moments when my wife wanted
to kick me out and that's fair not kick
me out forever but like you should
probably leave right and I'm a lot I get
that and there's been times I'm like I
don't want to be around her that's fear
who kicked out a newborn
yeah it was um
it was supposed to be only a two-month
like he said oh let's give it two months
and then we can reconnect as like a
the heart like distance makes the heart
grow fonder
yeah that works so good
I found
um yeah
yeah literally
with this other woman from the gym and
he said no it's strictly platonic
you're looping on it
you
are like somebody who lost somebody that
you love deeply in an act in a car
accident and you keep going back and
looking at the accident photos you have
to stop doing that
you're not gonna find peace in what he
did
and your sweet body's been through this
before when your dad took off on your
family right
[Music]
so this has double weight because this
wasn't going to be what happened to you
foreign
I want you to
you're not asking so I'm just putting
this out there okay
um and you can just blow it off and that
won't bother me a bit
I think it's time for you to sit down
with
a counselor and say
dad left me and I still don't understand
why what I did
and
my first responder supposed to be a hero
husband
made a beautiful baby with me and he
left me and now that same seven-year-old
is inside of me asking me what's wrong
with me again
and you're gonna have to heal from that
question
because it's going to affect everything
you do for the rest of your life
and the truth is
the answer is nothing on both counts
you didn't make your husband cheat and
you didn't make your dad leave
will you hold that sweet little baby
close to your chest and promise that
baby that you will go get healthy is it
a girl or boy
a boy I want you to commit to yourself
and that little boy
that this generational hurt stops with
you
and you're gonna go do the work that you
need to do
to make peace with the demons that are
still calling you from when you were a
little kid
and you're gonna get some
peace and some your footing underneath
you so you can make the hard decisions
that you got coming ahead
yes sir is that fair yeah
do you have some a bill you have some
resources to go see a counselor there in
your community
um I
was just they're just people I haven't
really connected with so I'm still
looking all right I want you just I want
you to stay on the line I'm gonna hook
you up with several months of better
help for free okay okay and that's a
good place for you to start
mm-hmm
are your parents trustworthy or is his
parents trustworthy do you have friends
there in California
okay everyone
so I want you to go sit with one or two
women that you trust
that you love and that you care about
and you can be honest with and I want
you to sit down and tell them everything
but I don't want you to rehash all the
the what happens the everything I'm
talking about is I want you to tell them
how devastating this was
won't you tell them how much it hurts
and how confusing figuring out your next
right step is because I can hear your
you have a very
trauma based response going on right now
which of course makes sense but you're
going back trying to figure out what
happened so that you can
justify going back with this guy if you
end up back with him you end up back
with him I'm not gonna hate on you for
that
but there's got to be some healing that
happens or this whole thing this whole
Loop starts over again and starts over
again
and again as I said when this call
started
he's a person who is so void of
character and so void of Integrity his
words get that same level of
um weight in your life the same weight
as his actions do
which should be zero because he doesn't
tell the truth that's not it's not who
he is
it's not who he is
can he come around yeah
is he going to probably not
but if he's listening to this
bro you better be on the next plane out
or everything you're you are just talk
just talk talk talk talk talk
and you're burying your sweet wife
and this little boy